hi i'm riya today i'll show you how to
make tempura at home
[Music]
so good tempura shouldn't be soggy or
soft or fluffy good tempura should be
crispy
and today i'm going to show you how to
make crispy tempura for the butter you
will need cake flour ice cold water and
egg cake flour has less protein so it
creates less gluten it will create
lighter butter
you also want to use ice-cold water but
don't put ice in the water it creates a
temperature difference around ice
make sure everything is cold including
your ingredients when you're mixing
flour don't over mix it i'm using four
chopsticks instead of using a whisk so i
don't over mix the butter so let's prep
the shrimp first cut the tip of the tail
and using your tip of your knife and
scrape the dirt and water inside if you
don't do that sometimes the tail
explodes sounds a little bit dangerous
shrimp tend to curl up when it's cooked
so cut small incisions on both sides
this will prevent the shrink from
curling up and you can keep a nice long
shape
let's prep the vegetables for the
eggplant cut and remove the stem then
make 5 to 6 half inch thick slices
throughout the eggplant this way you can
shorten the frying time for eggplant and
it will make a nice presentation when
you're frying vegetables that have a
smooth surface like a squash or eggplant
coat them in a flower lightly before
dipping in the batter make sure to dust
off excess flour this way the batter
sticks better and coat the ingredients
evenly if you're frying something thick
like kabocha squash fry at 320
fahrenheit so it will cook through once
they are fried hold the tempura above
the oil a little bit to drain off excess
oil then transfer to a cooling rack and
drain oil almost standing it up for
eggplant you also want to cook with
flour lightly and dip in tempura butter
you want to fry around 3 40 high and you
want to fry two to three minutes
for shrimp coat them in a flour lightly
before dipping in the batter
raise temperature to 350 fahrenheit once
you drop shrimp into the oil
dip your fingers into the batter and
drizzle batter over the shrimp it will
create more coating around shrimp and
makes extra crunchy shrimp tempura
and you made a tempura
soft tempura immediately with a dipping
sauce or seasoned salt like matcha salt
thank you for watching i hope you
learned some tricks and tips making
tempura i hope you enjoy making templar
home
oh yes
you